Taylor Swift takes on jury duty Taylor
skipped Sunday night's VMAs but not to
avoid Kanye West and Kim Kardashian
instead she was performing her civic
duties Taylor showed up to jury duty in
Tennessee early Monday morning this snap
was taken by a fan at the courthouse he
gushed over how nice she was and I
witnessed lzt everyone felt that way
about the superstar quote I really
appreciate that she showed up for jury
duty in our city
despite her celebrity status she was
very gracious and I was proud that my
jury duty peers were very respectful it
made it a really good day this local
reporters Twitter account documents the
events on Twitter noting it was a heavy
case domestic assaults kidnapping and
rape Taylor is currently involved in a
sexual assault case of her own and
according to the reporter was eventually
dismissed as a potential juror also
Monday Kanye tweeted as this pick after
his epic VMA night
Addie that shows half of his album art
and half of Taylor's he's seemingly
extending an olive branch to Taylor
after their now infamous famous drama
he wrote unity love he's got a lot of
amazing ideas he's one of those people
who's just like idea idea idea